Ubisoft yeah 3 2016 they're gonna be
there showing off video games they're
not gonna show us houses while they're
not launching one this year maybe I'll
show and who knows they might show for
honor they might show Ghost Recon
wildlands but they're partly gonna show
watch dogs too they're definitely gonna
show watchdogs to whoever we like it or
not that that is happening you're gonna
get that watch dogs too if you're
watching this live then this is before
any sort of watch dogs to announcements
stuff we are thinking they're going to
announce something soon the leak at the
moment is the IGN had a full page
takeover of their website I feel like I
feel live for the missus unfortunately
that happens I think it's kind of fire I
know we all do it so when it happens to
them yeah laughs you've always been
really unlucky because they kept watch
dogs to under wraps yeah then some actor
yes exactly she was like I'm so he's got
glasses on thanks Ubisoft in his six
shades that was the youtuber the actor
before him when I was like he's a model
he's like I'm in watch dogs to also
check out my abs wow he's got some
numbers on me so it's like oh I guess
you're in watch dogs to also watch folks
to is a picture so what more things up
they haven't the game hasn't been
revealed yet yes still like dude
wonderful reveal of the game at you
three yeah we don't know what a day all
we seem to be able to take from it is
that there's an african-american
protagonist and that it is set in San
Francisco sure enough come American
protect me that's what the so there was
a screen yeah there was an Instagram
shot from some sort of Moak hop artist
about two weeks ago I think or maybe was
shows a little longer than that long
enough and of an African American
character wearing basically the sort of
bandana and then some glasses and a hat
which was like very very watchdog Z and
then basically that same character who's
picked was on yeah there is there and
then that same picture has appeared sort
of wood in better lighting on the front
page take over for IGN so that's very
interesting not just because obviously
diversity in games is very good but in
terms of like I'm somebody who lives in
oakland and used to live in san
francisco and like gentrification and
the sort of pushing out of minorities
within San Francisco to Oakland
has been so it is like part of the daily
life the culture of this area so if
they're doing that then that's like well
done because that the two stories are
happening around the bay area is that
the gentrification and all you know rich
people basically pushing people out that
and the tech boom which is watchdogs
perfect fits yeah i think it's where
they've chosen san francisco right i
mean this is software center of america
basic yeah the world it's a bit of your
maybe yeah yeah so i think it's probably
a good idea for setting i'm considering
the game spot and all the game big games
companies are located in san francisco
that there are gonna be a lot reviews
about the accuracy of yeah you know the
location but I'm you know I think you've
have a rica chance with watch dogs to to
establish the franchise yeah this is
kinda the first watch dogs I thought it
was very forgettable and even it didn't
deliver on on any of its like it's the
classic Ubisoft maneuver right
Assassin's Creed one comes out and we
were like holy smokes it's bright
incredible and it was shallow it had a
lot of good ideas but just did not
deliver on any of them hey man I like
cuz I screwed one I like you as well
I'll tell you is your favorite toys oh
my boy is like the most arab dude in
video games ever I was like fully Arab
like this guy like so but like they
always their second games generally turn
out to be much better games are the ones
that kind of establish the template
going forward let's not forget that
watch dogs one trying to do so much I
mean this is a brand-new up here an
open-world game release for six
platforms the site I mean I said tall
order isn't it yeah that's a big R and
this was right at like the sort of them
like the highest point of ubisoft's like
massive machine you know software
development cycle like of them hauling
in thousands and thousands and thousands
of people you see the culture there
seems to be a little bit of okay that
they've taken stock of what happened
with Assassin's Creed they may be his
watch dogs was probably like one of the
least impactful new IP as they've had in
a long time especially in the third
person action adventures I was not a fan
of the first game at all i was very
disappointed by it yes but like you even
I'm there's something about this enough
time has passed I think they they nobody
knows more about how good or bad a game
is and the pea
who made it like they know they didn't
need the media to say anything didn't II
can seem just as true though because
what is it when you when you're working
on a game for so long you don't really
can't see it anymore right you're
slightly deep in the game and I think
that's the case I feel like when it
comes to the end though yeah must they
must be able to like sit back and go
right yes yes a lot of stories about
developer saying like the bug that
you're complaining about or the thing
the design element that you're
complaining oranges we you know we yeah
I find developers try and justify all of
the time is over right nor I feel like
they liked anything I feel like they do
justify it but I feel like deep down
they know maybe we over cuz you hardball
interview them across let's get on to
somewhere the games go out a bunch of
stuff to talk about f4 honor I'm really
surprised hair like much hype there is
around this game whatever we do are like
weekly breakdowns of all the games
people are searching for on gamespot for
honor has been consistently there all
year long has been in the top like five
life sometimes so little of it I'm not
yeah hardly any and every time I think
about I think just think about like
infinity blade and rice it was like a
mobile game that's been expanded into a
triple a title like it isn't coming off
the sort of Dark Souls like I like it
looks like a dynasty words and not even
by see what it feels like is literally
infinite like you're getting these
one-on-one encounters from point to
point you know Dennis Lee where it feels
like a mass kind of like large-scale
battles yeah well this is like you
you're a Viking and now you gotta fight
a samurai yeah stuff to figure out how
to deflect the text and it's so weird
but like I'm really interested in seeing
more of it mainly because that bearded
dude was a mega hype last time like i
wanna i want to know what he knows I
want to drink why he drink yeah I played
four in the last year and I wasn't
really expecting too much going into it
mmm but I had a lot of fun playing it so
it's basically this big massive battle
sword sword fights and whatnot yeah and
so you're playing against loads of a is
much like dynasty boys just slicing
people down but like you can also play
other people online okay as well at the
same time so you get involved in like
singular battles within about precisely
yeah so like you know in a dark knight
rises right yes for there's that big
massive fight outside of the main
building two of them have enough yeah
and they have a show
but they like the xterra each other in
the middle of that massive fight and
they're like yeah Alice and nobody's
just comes up and stabs him in the mouth
no then shoots him in the head but like
the game is trying to recreate that
moment right you see someone who's just
as good as you like in a big battle yeah
and face up against them and I I was
really impressed by I thought it was
refund and another game we roll probably
see a lot of Ghost Recon wildlands
they've always are trickling and
information about more and more and that
was a fun announcement I like I'm a big
fan of the ghost recon like the old ones
and then I actually really liked
advanced warfighter as well and this
though I mean they fumbled the whole
four player co-op thing a couple of
times though like crew and like there
was a couple it was a while there were
every ubisoft game had no problem i have
with with wild loans is the ghost recon
named existed before ubisoft switches
template months Tom Clancy was a rainbow
six min exactly so it means like it are
they going to try and fit that game into
an existing template like is it going to
be far cry plus the crew trial far cry +
Assassin's Creed are they going to
actually create a new unique like you
know Ghost Recon style gameplay for
their own game I feel like if it's the
the original if this using a current
template I'll be less interested in it
but as if they try and it like bring
some of what made the original ghost
recon games interesting and tactical and
they're so tactical they're like on
there like hidden in dangerous level of
like exactly omens moment there's
nothing else that offers that right now
that's true like so the moment the
studio is flaunting how big the world is
like their PR line the minute I get so
worried right and publishers do those
hey this is the biggest landmass sure if
we're gonna play along as like is there
anything else good about this yeah yeah
cuz if it's just another open world like
I mean the crew is the biggest thing
ever and that's that was like a big
problem then I think that worries me is
the diffusion just came out right and
data that's a very easy like copy paste
yes just remove all these dudes put some
drugs in hair shipping which they
presumably would have been working on
before the division has had it sort of
rise and fall I guess yeah and although
I'm sure it was very profitable as well
yeah it'll be interestin world hit man
with a you know dabble of cocaine
cowboys then maybe that's pretty cool
but you know the Devils in the detail
with these type of games that will have
to wait and there's also a lot of news
about possibly a new
triple a online game this has been
floated around for a while yeah that's
it that's a gonna have to speculate on
that but I feel like a lot of people
will feel similar to me where they're
like Ubisoft new triple-a and you're
like all right and then they go online
and you go hmm or rabbids yeah are you
telling me just dance online is coming
is that what's happening here I'd to be
fair to yourself every III the past four
years five years now sure they've stolen
the show or threatened to steal the show
with a big new game usually a new IP
yeah but they've presented and paraded
really smartly right I mean to division
yeah or watch the watch dogs watch dogs
was the big 10 2012 watch dogs I think
about any about any of that just bring
back prince of persia right really came
back get him on the road like that's the
syriza in might they might do that i
mean they love doing that thing with
those are just gonna be new a new IP but
irish the prince of oh I see what you're
saying I feel like it's a new Tom Clancy
IP yeah exactly brand new IP com
constantino of the verb really well done
yeah it was it South Park stuff gets
trotted out during you be Santa's are
right yeah fractured bought whole
direction but all we saw last year you
probably some more of that and I mean
yeah they've said that they're going to
announce at least one new IP at e3 or
earlier we haven't seen it yet so
presumably then it is also a little
handful of Ubisoft via virtual reality
games that are getting trotted out at
Eagle flight and werewolves within as
well so Eagle flight is the game when
you're just lying you're a [ __ ] Eagle
man is an amigo that you're flying and
that's it that's it 15 pounds please now
you don't understand we are right yet
there's 15 rounds Oh 704 oh yeah of
course on how about werewolves are thin
which is basically a virtual reality
game or hanging out with friends yeah of
a game you might surely can play in real
line real life but this one's licenses
to understand any apparently treaty good
Alexa played we're looking at the eagle
flight here Alexa I mean every I love
the the Reds little thing it's like
yarny stuck to a [ __ ] pigeon and butt
haha yeah yeah Alexa played the
werewolves it in apparently had absolute
blast with it so I mean maybe I can see
that being cool if you're playing would
like
random people I you know that's weird
right to be like VR and then with random
people know I never don't know you're
naked on the internet off don't know
laughter oh no no no it was great you
got to watch people do like cocaine in
their little of xbox live cameras really
oh man you should that was horrific oh
you should have a you know like three
years after came out was dark yeah the
only people think who know were like
this is this is chatroulette before chat
room yeah totally like fifty fifty
percent chance I was clearly missed that
one you know I was crying is great oh
yeah Danny what do you think about the I
mean like usually seeing people quite
cynical about it then they put the
helmet on anela oh my god this is
amazing and then I think it's amazing
it's just how amazing is it to get to
the sticker price for it and I mean
we're gonna get cheaper and cheaper I
still think there's a bunch of amazing
games that have commented that the best
thing that I've ever done and it was the
oculus we're getting a little bit
sidetracked over the oculus touch thing
which was like very much a you know
communication experience like a new
version of skype it felt like you know a
paradigm shift I felt like something
that I never would have thought of so
when I see companies like Ubisoft we're
making like these like small little
experiences I mean enough of these right
if they talk about wearable for their an
eagle fly maybe one or two more little
ones like the more and more games there
are it's like when you buy a console
after a year even though you're not
going to buy all the games that have
been released the fact that there is
this library is like this comfort
blanket that makes you feel better about
spending four hundred dollars so if
there's enough of these virtual reality
games and if people are and we know some
you're going to show off a load we know
there's a massive you know they're gonna
be showing a lot on the stage for their
gonna show a lot at their conference you
know if games like this you know where
was within and whatnot they're like
interesting little side notes then
enough of those make it worthwhile then
you still have the killer apps I'm
saying these games from you stuff they
will add to the pile by saying yeah I
think so and you know eventually after a
while it becomes you know a bit more
worthwhile so that's Ubisoft I mean
watchdogs to we're definitely to see
Assassin's Creed last note on this
there's none coming at this year will we
saw another one who really really smart
move to know yes release another they
should like not engage your Assassin's
Creed this year right yeah a movie let
Fassbender have his moments I mean
that's the thing that the taking a year
off with also doing the movie yeah I
mean is that really a year off right
also because they're kind of breaking
the tradition they might break tradition
in the way they reveal the stuff so it
might be that we get a little teaser a
logo or something yeah at the event but
then carry on like revealing it later on
down the line is one year gonna be
enough
are you gonna want Assassin's Creed
again if they if they that's a good
point because I needed to for watch dogs
yeah yeah so yeah maybe it will be a
little longer and I hope so because that
franchise a love button is in dire need
of a reboot right so you both live in
last point is he both live in London
what was your feel on syndicate I
thought was okay i like the characters
finally like I haven't like very many of
the previous suit like wrightwood cam
way and connor kenway and whoever the
hell was before that yeah these Easter
eggs well okay yeah these two guys were
all right like eV and Jacob I think his
name is why not sure yeah like they were
cool i like that london look nice but
I'd I honestly I didn't play all the way
through it yeah I did at nine in that
last like i can play I device I mean I
you know fair play to the developers
that they're very talented they do a
great job but I just can't play now if
you had your same for a while I yeah i
think that the kind of like the quick
grapple thing kind of took it out for me
like i like right I like the mechanics
of jumping and grabbing and maintenance
stuff grow home yep I don't get that in
Assassin's Creed game over that go home
totally best accessory came that the
certainly last year's best of all the
chaos manager yeah go home was great I'd
love to see more of that or get that
technology into his house is great i'll
be absolutely brave and that's what we
think you'll be stopped going to show
off watchdogs to for honor wildlands a
new IP a bunch of your stuff maybe a
little nod to assassin's creed and
perhaps a prince of persia let us know
what you would like to see in the
comments blow and it does subscribe
button for more III rumors young game
from
you